in a few days the world leaders are
gathering in Davos at the world economic
forum to discuss how to improve the
state of the world my name is Lloyd
clemmer and I'm going to moderate the
social networking panel of Davos all the
main social network leaders will be
there twitter myspace ning facebook
linkedin all of them you can participate
in the debate by asking a question which
we will show during the conversation in
front of all those world leaders here is
how you do it you go to youtube.com
slash Davos you press the submit a
question button and then you can ask a
question or leave a comment here is a
question has the rise of social networks
improved society the videos with the
highest number of votes will be
displayed in front of a world leaders
and we will discuss it so go ahead do it
now